الوضع العام هنا في محيط ملعب المدينه
التعليميه حيث بدا الجمهور السعودي في
التوافق قبل ما يقارب ساعتين عبر مسيرا
نظامها منتظمه الى داخل الملعب بالبعض
استطاع الدخول الى الملعب والبعض الاخر
لازال في مسيرته الى في طريق الملعب في
الحقيقه انا يتواجد معي عدد من الجمهور
السعودي الذي يريد ان يحضر هذه المباراه
ويستمتع برؤيه الاخضر السعودي في همم ثاني
ظهور له في المونديال همم حدثنا في
البدايه تفضل هنا حدثنا عن توقعاتك هذه
المباراه كبيره قدم المنتخب السعودي امام
الارجنتين اليوم بولندا وليفاندوفسكي ولا
ايضا من طراز الكبير اكيد المباراه اليوم
كبيره ان شاء الله مباراه تكون حلوه
شبابنا شباب المنتخب باذن الله يسوونها
باذن الله اتوقعها اثنين واحد نفس مباراه
الارجنتين بالضبط تفاعل كبير خالد كمال
وشاهد هنا في واحد همم بيكلمنا عن توقعاتك
المباراه اليوم ان شاء الله
منتخب السعودي ان شاء الله اليوم يبيضها
وان شاء الله يتقدم مستوى مامول منه وممول
من اللعيبه ان شاء الله انهم يكونون قد
التحدي باذن الله ان شاء الله راح نشوف
الفوز باذن الله بالحماس والثقه اللي
عملوها قدام الارجنتين اليوم راح يقدمونها
ان شاء الله طيب انا معي واحد من المشجعين
هنا شفته همم بين الجمهور البولندي ما
اعتقدت انه سعودي
كلمني عن توقعاتك اليوم ان شاء الله
يمسكون ليفه يلعبون على على ليفه فقط
اذا لعبوا عليهم ان شاء الله باذن الله
السعودي تشكيله اليوم شفتها
ان شاء الله ان المنتخب يفوز ونقول
منتخبنا فوقها من السحب منتصرين باذن الله
باذن الله المنتخب السعودي يفوز بالمباراه
باذن الله عندها عامل كبير فيه يشرف كل
العرب
ايضا حتى معاي زرعه عربيه كبيره جدا
للمنتخب السعودي في هذه همم في هذه في هذا
المونديال تحديدا وقبل الدخول الى ملعب
همم المدينه التعليميه لكل المتوجه تفاعل
ايضا هناك تخوف من بعض اللاعبين ذوي
التراث العالي المنتخب الهولندي